j'ai 63 ans je suis atteinte de sclérose
en plaques depuis près de 30 ans et
surtout d'arthrite rhumatoïde sévère
depuis 12 ans je ne marche plus je
souffre je porte des culottes
d'incontinence
j'ai des plaies de pression et j'en
passe madame et messieurs afin de
permettre à vos proches et à nous tous
un jour d'avoir le droit de mourir dans
la dignité
permettez vous aux électeurs oui ou non
d'alléger la loi actuelle comme le
recommande la juge baudoin de la cour
supérieure du québec
mais ce bien sûr s'ancrer d'embûches
supplémentaires merci merci infiniment
madame pigeon je vous reviens après les
réponses
madame et vous êtes la première à
répondre notre beau j'en suis vraiment
touchée par votre situation et je veux
donner vos mails sympathie est aussi un
engagement parce qu'on doit changer sa
loi
j'ai fait mes affaires dont le parlement
dont l'étude les projets de loi pour
permettre à l'aidant moururent est la
dignité les doigts des citoyens de
choisir de façon à les moments de mort
en discuter je veux faire encore le même
chose dans le prochain parlement
merci madame et monsieur singh madame ma
réponse est oui
et merci infiniment pour avoir le
courage de partager une question assez
difficile et pour partager vos histoires
qui aussi tellement difficile ça prend
beaucoup de courage et je veux vous
remercier et c'est clair avec le
jugement au québec que les critères sont
trop limitées et ça ne donne pas la
dignité
donc ce que je veux faire c'est de en
lever les limites parce que c'est trop
limité je veux vous donner plus de
pouvoir d'avoir le droit de mourir dans
la dignité
c'est une décision difficile mais il
faut avoir accès trois importants donc
oui je suis avec vous et oui on peut le
faire
merci monsieur singh monsieur blanchet
la réponse est très évidemment oui c'est
un phénomène très nouveau
cette loi c'est une philosophie nouvelle
au québec comme au canada et je vous
félicite et je félicite les gens qui
sont allés au tribunal parce que vous
vous êtes emparés de cette loi là vous
avez dit maintenant c'est à nous ont
aussi participé à commence à votre vie
père comment ça va s'appliquer
je pense que le gouvernement les
gouvernements doivent s'engager
fermement à respecter le jugement sans
condition qui est à travailler en
parallèle par la suite à continuer à
bonifier ces lois là il est essentiel
que le jugement soit respectée merci
monsieur blanchet monsieur trudeau merci
madame pigeons pour votre question et
pour votre courage d'être avec nous si
ce soir c'est une question extrêmement
personnel pour les individus pour les
familles il nous devons être là en tant
que gouvernement pour vous aider à
naviguer ces questions difficiles
oui nous allons alléger la loi dans les
prochains six mois parce que nous
reconnaissons depuis le début que
c'était une nouvelle loi un équilibre
qu'il fallait chercher entre la
protection des plus vulnérables et le
respect des droits et des choix de
chacun chacune et on comprenait même il
ya 3 3 4 ans quand on a mené seule cette
voie là que les tribunaux la société
tout allait évoluer et nous on va
évoluer avec mercy faute question merci
monsieur triaud monsieur remercie
beaucoup pour la question et a bon
courage à vous avez tous mes sympathies
c'est évident que c'est l'enjeu très
près sain et je dois dire que ce c'est
une des moments que j'ai trouvé que tous
les partis au parlement a vraiment
essayé de trouver a le teint comme une
bonne voie pour à répondre euros à vos
décisions de court mais en même temps de
trouver l'équilibré pour protéger les
régions vont meubler les choses comme ça
à est âprement nous allons toujours
respecté les décisions de court en même
temps on va faire une revue de la
décision et de divers que régis parce
que quand monsieur blanchet dit ça c'est
vrai tellement nouveau système régi ici
au canada doit assurer qu'on retrouve
le bon moi merci monsieur chemin
conclusion monsieur bernier oui
effectivement cette fois là doit être
révisée moi je peux vous dire que j'ai
voté en faveur au fédéral de la loi sur
mourir avec dignité et on prendre la
liberté la responsabilité individuelle
au parti si populaire je m'apprête
effectivement m'engager à regarder cette
législation là et s'assurer que les gens
qui prennent cette décision difficile
avec leur père soit capable de faire ce
qu'ils veulent faire pour leur fin de
vie
donc vous avez complètement l'appui du
parti populaire dans votre démarche
merci monsieur bernier merci surtout
madame pigeon vous êtes la plus
courageuse d'entre nous ce soir ici
merci beaucoup
d'avoir eu le courage de venir nous
parler chez que c'était pas facile
nécessairement et c'est un débat
important et qui va suivre son cours on
viens de l'entendre
merci madame pigeon bonne fin de soirée
merci merci